Salut c'est les Pêcheurs de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes dans le centre historique de la ville de Narbonne
Vous avez le canal ici, c'est magnifique
Il ne fait pas beau mais ça ne va pas nous empêcher de très bien pêcher à l'aimant
Ouais il y a du lourd ici
Vous l'avez vu nous ne sommes pas seuls mais avec Fabrice et Aymeric
pour la partie 2 que nous vous avions promis
Parce que vous aviez apprécié la partie 1 avec la découverte de deux pistolets
Rasta est aussi parmi nous
Et ici il y a un gros poisson qui semble mal en point
Un gros Sandre
On lui donne encore sa chance mais s'il reste là il va finir au barbecue
Nous sommes vraiment en plein centre de la ville avec Rasta
Et mon aimant est collé sur quelque chose de gros
je me demande ce que cela peut-être
Oh
ça se soulève, regardez les bulles
regardez ces bulles
Ah un poteau ?
Et voilà
Bien joué Rasta c'est grâce à toi
Alors
Une bouteille de protoxyde d'azote
Ok...
Il y en a de partout ici, cela ne m'étonne pas
Oh non encore une
encore une bouteille
Ola t'as du lourd là !
ça a lâché
Ton père est presque tombé en arrière et toi tu y retournes directement
Il est motivé !
Oh un caddie de grand mère
c'est original
C'est le caddie de Mami, on en a déjà trouvé mais  pas comme celui-là
La pauvre mami Nova elle avait mis le cadenas et tout pour ne pas se le faire voler
Purée
Il a des freins et tout
bien joué
On a déjà trouvé un fauteuil roulant aussi
Ah oui, nous aussi mais en morceaux
Ouais un bout
Je vous vois venir dans les commentaires, "il y a la grand mère aussi au fond"
il faut la retrouver
Troisième protoxyde d'azote
Il y a beaucoup de cannettes qui flottent là
C'est original...
Oula ça c'est du bon vieux tube
C'est bien Rasta
Vous la sortez cette chaise de bar ?
Elle n'est pas aimantée
Ah ouais ?
Il faut utiliser deux aimants
Un de chaque côté
regarde
Voilà impeccable
On le sait que t'es malin mon fils
bravo, cool
Attention à la plaque
Oh la galère
Bien joué
regardez comme cet endroit est beau
On est pas bien ici ?
C'est moi qui suis beau
non, Rasta est beau
Ouah encore
le proto
Le mobilier urbain c'est aussi un grand classique
dans les villes
Ah ouais belle prise
On peut aimanter les aciers et le nickel
Mais par contre parfois il reste des choses dans ces coffres forts, ça peut arriver
Si les cambrioleurs ont trié un peu rapidement
On trouve des coffres forts parfois
Se sont des bombonnes de protoxyde d'azote
Le gaz hilarant
Ici il doit y en avoir beaucoup, oui
Un fléau dans les grandes villes
Ben, bonne pêche
Merci, bonne journée
Encore un fer à repasser
Il est de meilleur qualité ? Ah non il c'est aussi cassé
J'ai quand même quelque chose, un briquet
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Une chaise
En plastique
Pourquoi j'attrape ça avec un aimant ?
Protoxyde d'azote
Voilà, le cinquième
Allé, la sixième
La septième
Ah ! Huitième
Aussi une clef
Qu'est-ce qu'il mange ?
Non !
Donne, donne, donne
Quentin ! Il a un truc dans la bouche
Tu laisses Arthur Richard Dillon tranquille
Oh oui, une pince
Elle est neuve
Ca c'est cool
On a trouvé plein mais neuves à ce point, c'est la première fois
Un sécateur neuf
Allé, on garde
Oh ! Regardez
Un porte clef crucifie
Il y a un dessin à l'arrière, comme un voile
Sympa
Il y a une colombe à l'avant
Je garde
C'est une bite d'amarrage
Celle là est super belle
Encore ...
Elle est vraiment  lourde
Bien joué
Regardez, le blason de la ville de Narbonne dessus
Très sympa
Un objet historique
Ils les ont remplacés par des toutes petites qu'on peut voir au bord
Rasta, tu reste ici, attention !
Deux en un coup, bravo
On va en trouver une cinquantaine aujourd'hui je pense
Là j'ai sorti un porte monnaie je crois
Je ne sais pas si il est vide
On va essaye de l'ouvrir
Il faut utiliser le couteau
Viens, on va filmer l'ouverture
Il y a des pièces, je crois
Il y a quelques pièces
C'est des petites
C'est une première pour nous un porte monnaie avec des pièces
C'est peut être des francs
Imagine un Louis d'or
Je vais chercher la cisaille
On dirait le symbole Magnetar
Il y a un autre poisson là
Attend, on est dans le sang du poisson, ce n'est pas esthétique
Vous êtes prêt ?
Je suis sûr qu'il y a quelques pièces
Oui il y en a
Des euros, pas des francs
2012 celle là
Elles sont en bon état. - Oui elles sont brillantes
Regardes, une sorte d'aimant de frigidaire
C'est pour gratter la guitare
Ah oui ! C'est un médiator
Vous avez besoin d'aide ?
Ca va ?
Ca va toujours quand je récupère l'aimant !
Merci les gars
On c'est décalé, sous une passerelle
C'est bon signe regardez il y a du sang partout dans les escaliers.
Ca veut dire qu'il c'est passé quelque chose
Ils ont peut être vidé un poisson mais ca veut qu'ils ont des couteaux
On va pêcher ici
C'est un couvercle de boîte
Bien joué, c'est une veste ?
Un mini couteau Laguiole
Celui-là est en bon état
Parfait
Tiens Aymeric, je t'ai trouvé un mini Laguiole
Il y avait quelque chose dans la vase
Un vélo !
T'as raison un dirait un peu un Peugeot
Ah d'accord, une trottinette
Ce n'est même plus le vélo
Trottinette aussi
Pas mal
Oui, deux d'un coup
A peu prêt les mêmes
Une pince en plus ?
En bon état aussi, cool
Allé ! De deux !
Fais voir ?
Ce n'est pas un Laguiole ...
Mais ca reste un couteau
Voilà le petit vélo, il était bien lourd
On a trouvé un sac
On dirait un cartable
Il y a quelque chose d'aimanté dedans
Attendez, attendez
C'est bon signe qu'il soit aimanté en bas
C'est une sacoche
Oh il y a une bouteille !
Ca ne doit pas être du bon vin
Mais si, ca se boit
C'est quoi qui était aimanté au fond ?
C'est du vin ou du Porto ?
Non, attend n'ouvre pas
République Française en tout cas
L'étiquette est tombée
C'est couleur cuivre, est-ce que c'est aimanté ?
Oui, c'est surement plaqué
La bouteille, c'est très drôle
Une petite goulée à ta santé
Là on a un badge, des clefs et des centimes d'euros
Regardes moi toutes ces pièces
Encore !
1;2;3;4;5;6;7
Pas mal
Une fusée de détresse de bateau
On dirait une barre de traction
"Delta sport" Oui c'est bien ça
Pour faire des tractions
Je te donnes des pièces aussi dans cette poche
Regardez, une bague
Elle accroche à peine
Jolie bruit
Y-a-t-il des motifs dessus ?
Le sachet !
Pas n'importe quel sachet
Le sachet rempli de centimes